anti-terror raids in Berlin 250 police
officers and Special Forces carried out
search operations against suspected
Islamists authorities raided 12
properties two men were arrested but
police say there are also investigating
others the suspects are from turkey
Russia Chechnya and Dagestan they have
been on the radar for authorities for
months suspected of planning terror
attacks in Syria s Kido [ __ ] taking
measures against Islamist suspects our
investigation is focusing specifically
on five individuals suspected of
coordinating a terror logistic cell with
jihadists in Syria we believe they
supported terrorist activities in Syria
through financial and logistical means
if auntie Anna materialistic or
anatomically authorities believe several
hundred fighters have left Germany to
join Islamic state in Syria and Iraq
some have appeared on is videos
authorities fear they pose a major
security risk when they return to
Germany today's arrests followed the
detention of a German Tunisian yesterday
in the city of votes Berg he is
suspected of undergoing combat training
with Islamic state affiliates during a
trip to Syria